welcome back to future chain design this
is pj today i would like to talk about
this matching band or what they call
shadow bend and how to make it match to
the engagement ring and do a b setting
on top of it are you ready let's get
started
this is a demonstration how to making
this
ring bending any of a shape
that will matching for example from the
top view so you wear it you can wear
both of them on either side if you're
interested in how to make this cathedral
ring i do have a video here at the right
top corner you can click on the video
and to making this ring first if you
like to now we are going to starting
from the scratch to do this matching
band once you have a ring ready and then
you want to make a matching band we want
to coming into the top view and we kind
of need to draw the curve that will fit
into it so i'm kind of coming into
the top view and i'm going to use this
control point curve and you can draw it
as close to the ring as possible and i'm
going to hold my shift
going one more and coming up here i
would like to have a really gentle curve
and going something like this
now you don't have to draw all the way
to the the other side because we're just
going to mirror it right if you don't
like a curve you can still go ahead to
adjust it until you find that the curve
is fitting into the profile on the top
now once you have it you can just mirror
to the other side
using the mirror command snapping into
the zero coming over here and you're
going to have this cross over there we
can simply just using the trim command
and we want to trim this off and trim
this off okay so now i have it i just
don't like the kink that we may have
there so what i like to do to maintain
this not having a kink is i need to
align those three so i'm gonna use the
gumball 1d scale just type it zero so
that way i can prevent it this has a
kink over there now we can go ahead to
join this guy
after joining them you'll see it's
become a curve flattened to the
construction plane all right so the next
things we wanted to do is we need to
create this ring now you can use any of
the
profile you want for example i'm simply
just going to create some sort of
profile look like this and since i'm
going to set the stone i need to make
sure that my stone will while filling it
nicely so i'm going to use the
rectangle with the colony corner because
it's a small like a comfort fit there
and i'm going to bring it back a little
bit like this
make sure that this is not
too much of a difference from your main
ring if it is go ahead to change the
shape and change the size all right the
second thing is we actually need a ring
shank in a circle to represent the size
so i'm going to use the circle command
snapping into the zero and i'm going to
use diameter for 16 or radius for 8.
once we have that i actually want those
two to be aligned so let's go ahead to
align them
with the align tool and that's a line to
the top and bring it back here all right
so now those two curves align and i also
want to moving this one
from here
to
the intersection all to the quadrant of
that circle so then we can
sweep it there now the key is i need to
have this curve follow this circle so
that way to do it is using the curve
front two view we're gonna click on this
one and also click on this one and that
will give us this curve right there
it is going to be red color and i don't
need the one on the bottom so simply
we're gonna just pick up this one
and we're gonna trim the red on the
bottom so it's only on the top like this
right if you're going to sweep this guy
we're going to do the sweep one rail
this is the red
this is the cross section
and we'll get something like this
notice that this may not be exactly
facing up if that bother you you can
just adding another section right in the
middle let me show you what i mean i'm
going to have this one
and then i'm going to
rotate it
snapping to the zero and i want to
rotate it copy equal yes here on my
command bar
and i'm going to move it up 90 degree
like this
and just click ok
after i move it up i need to make sure
this is in the right place that's using
the move command and snapping from here
to here so now both cross section is on
my
rail and we can starting doing the sweep
one rail one more time this is the rail
this is cross section you got one you
got two cross section and you want to
make sure they are aligned in this case
i'm going to have them align
outside right there
so then we'll have it perfectly facing
up on the profile as you can see over
there
all right so that will be one the other
side you can simply just have this one
and mirror to the other side like this
all right notice that it's kind of
jamming a little bit so we might need to
move in this one out just make sure that
they are not jamming into each other all
right now we have this looking at the
top view and see if this is the angle
that you like if this is the curve that
you like if you like it then we can go
ahead to finish the bottom of the ring
shank since i already move it i'm going
to hiding this one and duplicate
the edges of this one right here and
also
this one right here i should have done
it before i move it but since i already
move it i want to show you another way
to make a perfect match
let's go to the sweep
one command and we want to click on this
rail
click it right here for the new curve
that we just duplicated here's the new
curve and we hit enter and make sure
that the seam is aligned and we want to
hit enter and that will create the
bottom of a ring shank you can go ahead
to join all the surface together
become one piece so now this is a closed
solid polished surface
all right let's talk about how to
arrange the stone on it you can download
the stone at the description below
there's a link for sign up the
newsletter after that you will receive a
link to download a roundstone
once you have the stone file you just
need to open it hit ctrl c which is copy
and coming into this file and hit
control v which is passed then you can
bring the stone back in here the stone
size is in five millimeter to size it is
quite simple we can just use in the 3d
scale and we're going to snap in here to
here and bring down to whatever size in
my case i might need to have 1.2
millimeter i'm going to hit enter there
after that i want to make sure it's back
in the center so i'm going to use a line
vertical and just type it zero here so
it will align back in the center now let
me moving my stone up here
and take a look on other view i want to
make sure the stone is in the right
place to start it with so i'm going to
have the stone right there your girdle
wanted to sit
above or right at the surface of your
ring
now we have the stone in place let me
simply just turn the stone into the cyan
color
and we want to make sure the stone is
follow some sort of a curve on this
surface so we do need to have a curve
i'm going to use the duplicate h command
and i'm going to pick up this one right
here and simply just changing this into
the green color just easier for you to
see now if you have done some of the
stone flow before you might using this
way let's pick up the
transform under the transform you have
array along curve command and then with
this we want to pick up the object which
is this stone hit enter it will ask you
what's the base curve and we're going to
hit it right here now at the beginning
you will the item is only 2 then you
will have 2 there but
you can increasing the number so for
example i'm gonna do 12 here and i look
fine let's click ok
notice that sometimes it works sometimes
it doesn't work in this case it seems
all right but if you take a look in the
detail notice that this one is kind of
diving into the
surface
so let's take a look what other things
that we can do i just size up my stone
just a little bit i think it will look
nicer to fitting into the width of the
ring shank that i have now that's using
the newer command
not new but possible i haven't been
using in my demo before is the array
along the curve on surface all right so
what it does it will ask you to pick up
the object which we're going to pick up
this stone it will actually say where's
the base point we're going to snapping
into the end point of this green curve
then which is the curve on the surface
which is this green one and what is the
surface i'm going to pick up this one
all right now you can see as soon as i'm
moving my mouse my stone will follow it
and it will be really nicely hopping on
the surface
you have the option to using the divide
which you can divide a whole grain curve
into a certain section or we can use a
multiply
i would like to have 9 copy in my
demonstration here and hit enter and the
distance for 1.5 millimeter and hit
enter so now you can see it is really
nice
evenly distributed into this screen
section because i set it up for 1.5
millimeter so it doesn't go all the way
to the bottom which is i think it's
great
with this amount of the stone if you
feel like you don't need that many stone
you can actually did it this one it will
keep the same distance in between so i'm
going to delete two more right there all
right the next things we wanted to do is
we need to make a prong
i'm going to draw a straight line right
here and doesn't need to go too long and
this straight line i want to just be on
the top of you moving to where it's
supposed to be and we're just simply
going to pipe it let's eyeball it for
how big it should be ideally you want
them to be big enough to able to cover
on both sides of the stone you want to
take a look also on
not only the top view also on the
perspective look like the one on the
right it seems covered more
the prong area so i'm going to pick up
the prong and just move it back to the
center
double make sure with the perspective
view look like even over there if you
like it just go ahead to make a copy
bring out with the gumball and just hit
the all key and so that way you were
making a copy right there
now if that worked for you we need to
make a duplication of this prong and
follow correctly on all the stone
however in the old time you might use
something like this
you want to use the command
for array along the curve
and i found that array along the curve
when you have on a really
straight surface there's no twisting
angle changing at all that will be fine
for example if i choose a base curve
and i choose whatever how many stones so
let's say we do seven
and seven apparently it's like too far
away so i'm going to do
and
you can keep changing until you get
something close right in the middle
right so this one look not too bad but
once you click it notice that the rest
of them it doesn't follow it and most of
the time you need to pick up the
individual frame and moving back to
whatever it is supposed to be
let me show you other way to do it you
can do it this way that will be fine but
i found the other way maybe more
efficient
we're going to use the same command
under the transform you have array and
then you have array a long curve on
surface
this time we want to pick up this
prong over here
and then we want the base point it's
really close to
the prong within the with the green line
so let me make sure the near is on and
we want to snapping right in the center
in between two stone okay
now the curve on the surface which is
this curve
and the surface which is our ring now if
i'm moving my prong and i'm able to
click on
where i wanted the prong to be by moving
the prong along with this curve that i
have so i kind of eyeball it where they
supposed to be a missing one there so
i'm going to come in back
make sure my only my near is on and so i
can correctly to
moving my prong there and double make
sure they are in the right place if it
is not maybe the angle i was looking at
it may not be 100
right angle so we can kind of be moving
around
and you just need a little adjustment
for the prong to be the right place
okay
so i will do the same thing on the other
side which i'm gonna pick up the prong
first and using the command
under the transform you have array along
the curve on the surface
and base point is somewhere near here
the curve is this one the target's this
one and i'm also going to fast forward
so then we'll go faster on this video
once we are done we just need to come
back and make sure all the prong is in
the right place
if that looking correct for you you can
just coming over to the top view i'm
sorry the front view and we can pick up
all of this we just have them to mirror
to the other side so that will complete
this b setting for this ring if you like
the video please leave a comment at the
description below and also like and
share my video more of the stone setting
technique you can find on the stone
setting playlist or on my course for
stone setting course on my website thank
you for watching and i will see you next
you